[Musik]
sprechen wir nach dem parteitag der
linken über die politik der partei die
linke und klar über ihre krone
krisenstrategie mit dem
bundesgeschäftsführer jörg schindler ist
am montag geschehen
guten tag es hinter wieviel öffnung muss
am mittwoch beim treffen von bund und
ländern kommen
ja es muss vor allen dingen eine
ausklang der ausgleichsmaßnahmen müssen
kommen
das krisenmanagement der bundesregierung
ist doch ein desaster
entscheidend ist jetzt dass wir endlich
ausgleichsmaßnahmen haben es muss ein
pandemie zuschlag geben zum beispiel die
impfstoffe müssen endlich freigegeben
werden zum beispiel es müssen die
gesundheitsämter besser ausgestattet
werden
die bundesregierung tut hier seit einem
jahr nichts oder nehmen wir die schulen
seit über einem jahr wissen wir dass wir
luftfilter brauchen passiert ist nichts
und das muss sich alles ändern die
bundesregierung will allerdings an ihrer
verschleppung linie bleiben und das ist
eigentlich nicht akzeptabel darum muss
es am mittwoch gehen hersteller wenn sie
sagen ausgleichsmaßnahmen verstehe ich
sie dann richtig dass öffnungen für sie
gar nicht das entscheidende thema sind
wir wollen nachhaltige öffnungen das
heißt allerdings dass wir dieses
lockerungs jojo vom vermeiden wollen es
soll nicht so sein dass wir öffnen und
dann gleich wieder schließen müssen
nachhaltiger ist es jetzt konsequent zu
handeln aber die sozialen härten die
konsequenzen für diejenigen zu
erleichtern die davon am stärksten
betroffen sind etwa die pflegekräfte
oder nehmen wir die kinder
es muss hier einen zuschlag geben nicht
nur einmal sondern dauerhaft oder nehmen
wir die kurzarbeiter rinnen und
kurzarbeiter da muss ab dem ersten tag
90 prozent kurzarbeitergeld gezahlt
werden und nicht erst deutlich weniger
und später das sind ja wieder diese
ausgleichsmaßnahmen nochmal zur
klarstellung öffnungen in diesem zu
diesem zeitpunkt jetzt schon anfang märz
würden sie sagen eher nein
ich warne vor voreiligen hoffnungen
ich glaube dass wir einen solidarischen
doch down brauchen wir müssen jetzt
konsequent bleiben wir müssen das virus
bekämpfen und besiegen aber durch andere
maßnahmen insbesondere durch eine
schnelle durch impfung insbesondere auch
durch eine freigabe der impf lizenzen
die bundesregierung tut hier weiterhin
nichts fünf bis sechs prozent der
bevölkerung sind erst geimpft andere
europäische länder etwa die türkei zum
beispiel hat viel höhere im fragen
wollen wir das auf uns sitzen lassen ich
finde das ist einfach ein versagen der
bundesregierung hersteller lassen sie
uns noch mal auf ihrem parteitag vom
vergangenen freitag und samstag schauen
sie haben nun neue rein weibliche
doppelspitze mit janine wissler und
susanne hennig will so die eine nicht so
hat gerade einmal 70,5 prozent an
stimmen geholt das ist ja nicht gerade
der rückenwind denen sie sich
wahrscheinlich für die neue
parteiführung gewünscht hätten oder na
ja beide haben starke ergebnisse
bekommen
so seien hennig welt so hat hier auch
einen gegenkandidaten aber viel
wichtiger ist doch dass wir als partei
geschlossen und mit diesem
aufbruchsignal in die jetzt vor uns
liegenden bundestagswahlen gehen
darauf haben sich in der partei alle
verständigt und ich will noch mal
deutlich sagen wir haben die dinge
geklärt im vorfeld die wir zu klären
hatten und jetzt gehen wir geschlossenen
wahlkampf mit einem klaren angebot wir
sind bereit auch zu regieren unter ganz
bestimmten bedingungen das sind die
bedingungen einer sozial ökologischen
politikwechsel wende
wir wollen das ist nicht so bleibt wie
bislang dass die öffentliche
infrastruktur ausgeblutet wird die
schuldenbremse muss weg und es müssen
natürlich soziale und ökologische
maßnahmen für eine für ein anderes
wirtschaften dringend eingeleitet werden
wir haben dazu auch wenig zeit das muss
ab september erfolgen hier sind dazu
bereit noch mal schauen wir noch mal auf
ihre doppelspitze janine wissler war
lange im trotzkistischen netzwerk marx21
das fordert sozialismus von unten und
explizit keine regierungsbeteiligung
frau her nicht weil so fordert genau
diese die regierungsbeteiligung ab nach
der bundestagswahl und steht für
realpolitik wie soll das beides zusammen
gehen
auch janine wissler hat doch erklärt und
das haben sie ja sicher auch mitbekommen
dass wir unter bestimmten bedingungen
das finde ich auch völlig richtig unter
bestimmten bedingungen mitregieren
wollen und zwar sind das ganz klare
konditionen
jede partei auch die unsere stellt
natürlich um sich an einer
bundesregierung zu beteiligen politische
rahmenbedingungen
das sind bei uns ein sozial ökologischer
wellen eine sozial ökologische wende
das ist auch und das will ich so
deutlich sagen das ist auch die
beendigung der auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr
weil ich will mal ganz deutlich die
frage stellen was haben denn 20 jahre
afghanistan einsatz in afghanistan als
frieden gebracht
diese frage müssen auch spd und grüne
beantworten wenn sie dort eine andere
auffassung haben als die klare position
von uns erhöhung der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit gerechten
welthandel
das sind doch die maßnahmen die
tatsächlich helfen und nicht bundes
deutscher soldaten irgendwo am
hindukusch verstehen sie das ja ein
schönes detail da sind uns ruhig dabei
bleiben denn das sagt ja vielleicht auch
was ihre ihre gesamtpartei aus ihr
verteidigungsexperte matthias will der
hat sich in teilen für auslandseinsätze
der bundeswehr klar ausgesprochen also
das gegenteil von dem was sie eben
gesagt haben hat sich dann jetzt auf dem
parteitag um den stellvertreter posten
im parteivorstand beworben und hat
verloren gegen tobias pflüger ihren
friedenspolitischen sprecher der eben
wie sie klarer gegner von
auslandseinsätzen ist also wie
realitätsfern ist diese partei die linke
auch matthias höhn hat sich nicht für
auslandseinsätze ausgesprochen sondern
wir matthias höhn hat verschiedene
fragen gestellt
bezüglich der stärkung des völkerrechts
für uns ist doch aber vor allen dingen
wichtig dass wenn wir das völkerrecht
stärken wie wir das tun wir wollen und
auch da ist matthias höhn in seinem
papier deutlich geworden wir wollen
abrüsten wir wollen die militär haus den
militärhaushalt senken und da ist er
sich mit tobias pflüger einig es gab
eine abstimmung über die beiden personen
und es gab natürlich auch eine
politische entscheidung darüber dass wir
an der forderung die bundeswehr aus
allen ausland
aus einem auslandseinsätzen abzuziehen
dass wir daran festhalten wollen das
will ich so deutlich sagen und damit
würden wir natürlich auch im september
in den bundestagswahlkampf ziehen
selbstverständlich das ist unsere
politische position
ich sage es noch einmal die anderen
parteien müssen begründen weshalb ein
afghanistan-einsatz nach 20 jahren nicht
zum erfolg geführt hat wir haben da ja
mal ein vorschlag jörg schindler der
bundesgeschäftsführer der partei die
linke in vielen dank hier im phoenix
tagesgespräch gerne danke